ننا كثير بنكون بصور ونحنا خايفين على
اولادنا خايفين على عائلاتنا وهذه
المعاناه النفسيه يكفي يكفيها ان انا يعني
نتحمل ونواصل عمليه التغطيه بشكل حيادي
وبشكل استقلالي جدا وبشكل مهني ورغم ذلك
يكون في دواخلنا هناك خوف على ابنائنا
وعلى اسرنا انه احنا فاقدين القدره على
التواصل مع مصادرنا اتصالات مقطوعه
مواصلات مقطوعه وقود مقطوع والاسوا من كل
هذا انه احنا في خوفنا المستمر على انفسنا
كمان مش مطمئنين ابدا على عوائلنا اللي هي
ايضا في اماكن مزوح بخصوص المشاكل
اللوجستيه التي نواجهها كصحفي فهي مشاكل
جمه يعني اول شيء نحن نعاني مع الانترنت
بشكل يومي باستمرار في كيفيه الارسال
كيفيه نعاون مع الكهرباء في كيفيه يعني
شحن جوالاتنا شحن كمبيوترات الارسال نعاني
ايضا مع الماء نحن والخبز نحن احيانا يعني
نستيقظ من الساعه الخامسه صباحا حتى نوفر
ربطه خبز سرنا قبل ان نذهب الى عملنا نوفر
قنا ميه حتى اسرنا تشرب ميه هذه المعاناه
بتخلينا صراحه انه لا نفكر تماما ومطلقا
في العمل وفقط نفكر ايضا فيرنا هي الامور
انا امبارح اول مره اشرب مي مالحه امبارح
شربت مي مالحه بالله لانه كان في ازمه في
المي مي
الشرب
بس اذا كان هذا اللي بتعتقد اسرائيل انه
احنا في سب طريقه
راح نرفع رايه الاستسلام فهي واهمه احن ما
ظل لنا خيارات اليوم الا اننا نبقى انك مش
حاسس في الامان في اي مكان لا في مستشفى
لا في مكتبات لا في المكان اللي انت فيه
لا خارج المكان لا داخل المكان هذا اولا
ثانيا انقطاع الخدمات الاساسيه اللي هي من
مياه من خبز من اكل مش علي انا واحد من
هالشعب زينا زي هالناس مش انه نحن صحفيين
انه احنا لا مرفهين وبتوفر لنا كل شيء لا
احنا زينا زي الناس احيان بمر 24 ساعه
رغيف واحد وان ما بنشوف لرغيف احيانا
ميه في 24 ساعه نحن نشعر بانه هناك مشكله
تطال كل عملنا اولا انقطاع المتكرر
للاتصالات والانترنت وصعوبه الحركه في
الشوارع حتى حينما نضع اشارات الصحافه
ونلبس هذا الزي الذي يفترض انه حمايه
للصحفي المتعارف عليه دوليا لكن الاحتلال
يستهدف الصحفيين في اماكن تواجد بهم يقطع
الطريق امام امكانيه نقل هذه الصوره من
قطع غزه للعالم هذا اللي له علاقه في
سلامتنا في الميدان نن مش مضمون انهم ما
يضربونا لا انه في حوالي 24 صحف تم قصفهم
سواء في بيوتهم او في مكاتبهم او خلال
مهمات عمل فهذا الشيء شيء مؤلم وشيء صعب
جدا ابراج اسقطت بها كثير من مكاتب
الصحفيين وهذا
ضاعف المعاناه لكن هناك رساله واضحه عند
الصحفين الفلسطينيين حتى اخر لحظه لن
ينقطعوا عن نقل الصور
بما اتيح لهم من ادوات وبما اتيح لهم من
جهد بشري بقدر اقول انه احنا اذا كان ما
قدرنا نطلع صوتنا وصورتنا على الرغم من
العرقله الاسرائيليه المتعمده لعملنا وعلى
الرغم من كل زملائنا اللي فقدناهم شهداء
الله يرحمهم فصوت الناس ما راح
يوصل